[Music]
the north korean leader kim jong-un has
been busy since the country started its
first major battle against a coven 19
outbreak in may
he's personally inspected pharmacies in
pyongyang
kim visited the country's headquarters
for epidemic prevention
and he held numerous meetings where he
berated officials for failing to prevent
the public health crisis
pyongyang officially announced its first
locally transmitted case more than two
years into the pandemic and since then
hundreds of thousands of what north
korea calls fever cases have been
reported daily it's really eye-opening
that kim jong-un would say it's the
worst crisis since the foundation of the
country
examining kim's recent pandemic policies
and public service announcements helped
to understand what resources are
available in the country as well as
what's lacking as a regime attempts to
stamp out the virus
in the early days of the pandemic north
korea closed its borders including a
shoot-on-site order for people
attempting to cross it and it worked to
keep the virus at bay but now with the
surge in cases fueled by the fast
spreading omicron variant the country is
taking new measures the message sort of
been to convince people
that the leadership
is working very hard for them one of the
first acts was to order the lockdown of
major cities still pyongyang has
reported more than 60 deaths and over 3
million fever cases case of fever that's
essentially euphemism for coronavirus
they have very limited testing capacity
the world health organization has said
since the start of the pandemic north
korea has tested about 64 000 people
that works out at less than 100 a day
the lack of testing capacity is one of
the major challenges in the country's
battle against the virus if you're
trying to do the lockdown strategy you
know you need to be testing people as
well
to be able to tell when it's safe for
people to come out
with mass testing not an option the
leader has looked for other measures to
tackle the crisis
kim has mobilized the military to help
ensure basic medical supplies are
available in the capital city where the
first cases were reported crews donning
hazmat suits have been disinfecting
streets factories and stores people in
pyongyang have been encouraged to wear
masks we've even seen you know kim
jong-un himself wearing
two masks but we did go to the border
area between south korea and north korea
we could see people walking around on
the north korean side
who are not wearing masks
so
the
presence of masks seems to be
not
complete across the country at least
perhaps you know the availability of
masks is one reason for that
kim's actions have also been accompanied
by public health segments on state
television
in this segment a presenter explained
how to take painkillers like paracetamol
for fevers to our knowledge they don't
have supplies of antiviral medicines
which treat uh coping what they're
looking at to treat these things sort of
basic medicines but if someone's got
severe breathing difficulties it's
obviously not sufficient
another segment advised viewers to wash
hands regularly
nurses to wear masks
and that those with fevers should
isolate
but one of the most effective ways to
combat the virus has been missing from
these public service announcements and
other covit policies and that's to get
vaccinated that's because there's no
known vaccines available in north korea
and the country has also rejected doses
from the world health organization and
south korea but recently it's reached
out to one of its closest allies for
help there have been flights by north
korean cargo planes from china
bringing in medical supplies quite
secretly actually if they haven't
announced this i don't think they want
to let their people know that they are
relying on another country to provide
supplies
health experts say that without vaccines
and testing capacity north korea risks
being overwhelmed by a health crisis not
seen since the country suffered a famine
that killed over a million people in the
1990s the population is particularly
vulnerable because of widespread
malnutrition and the decrepit state of
the country's medical system in rural
areas hospitals are reported to lack
supplies and some even operate without
the
electricity
of rural areas you know are more badly
effective which is where we see more
malnutrition i would say that this is
probably not going to trouble the regime
too much because
this is something that we saw in the
past during the famine of the 1990s but
the casualty rate is very high in the
capital in pyongyang that's potentially
destabilizing because that's where the
leadership relies on the people for
their support in order to keep the kim
family and kim kindergarten specifically
in power
but the pandemic isn't the only big task
on kim's plate as he enters the second
decade of his rule the regime faces
sanctions that have battered the
country's economy and it continues to
move aggressively forward with frequent
weapons tests
those things require a large amount of
attention from the leadership can they
multi-task that's a big question